[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jackie in
Ohio she writes I've been married to my
husband for 30 years he earns a six
figure salary and I've been a
stay-at-home mom he wanted to manage our
finances because working together
stressed him out and he didn't want to
argue oh jeez maybe if oh God he wasn't
a brat I thought we lived a good life
but on a recent vacation I over heard
him checking account balances on our
credit cards and became concerned so I
started quietly
researching I discovered he was tearing
up financial documents and throwing them
away so I couldn't see them he has
completed 95% of a job byout and taken
loans on what little retirement savings
he had less than 100K he refinanced our
homes multiple times rut so we still owe
2third of our mortgage after paying on
it for 20 years he also has over
$130,000 in debt outside of the mortgage
I now realize we've been living paycheck
to paycheck on a six-figure salary just
to avoid confrontation I'm going to stop
you there Jackie you haven't you have
been living paycheck to paycheck because
your husband's got something else going
on there's some significant deceit
whether it's an addiction it's somebody
else he's in love with or he's got other
pet projects he's trying to work through
um this is not just to avoid
confrontation this because he has a
different life when we should be living
and enjoying retirement together I now
work full-time and he does contract work
there are so many things wrong here how
do we move
forward so they're in their 50s 60s
there's been a long pattern where he's
quote handled the money and by handled I
mean mishandled they're deeply in debt
and she's trying to go like how do I
even begin to address this yeah
um I'm going to assume here George that
there's no abuse okay there's no
emotional abuse there's no physical
abuse okay if there is that of course
changes the
dynamic with that said both people are
at fault for here one the husband saying
no I I just I'm just going to do it I
don't want to argue with you and two her
going okay and then 30 years later 20
years later acting surprised oh my gosh
it's all gone sideways and bad right I
would be shocked if this marriage has
been great this whole time I assure you
it has not
and like this strategy never works to be
like well let me just handle it so we
don't fight about it and somehow you're
going to have a great marriage with that
lack of
communication with with no Financial
infidelity like this is exactly why we
tell people combined bank accounts and
have full communication right over
what's going on and full transparency
about what's going on in the finances
even if you're not the nerd you don't
want to have to be the one whittling the
budget down JN needs to know what's
happening in their budget correct and so
this is this has to be called out for
what it is he has been lying and
cheating on you for 30
years anything less than that bold of a
statement is watering it down and
patting you on the head and saying a
sweetie you'll be fine cuz honey you are
not fine this is Terri the numbers you
just laid out here are terrifying he has
been lying and cheating on you for 30
years and you have played your part by
looking the other way and never asking a
question because vacation time just
showed up and the presence just showed
up and the bills just magically got
whatever there's no way this has
happened that you haven't had some
inkling that things were
off things were off now again outside of
if he's abusive emotionally abusive this
has been unsafe it's not a matter of you
uh turning at your head it's a matter of
you laying low so you don't get your
head knocked off okay totally different
situation but if you both have just been
puttering along then you both have to be
part of the ownership
here um your husband's going to have to
get down on both knees and say I'm sorry
I have lied to you I have stolen from
our future I have cheated you will you
still keep me around and you're G to
have to say I'm sorry that I let this
thing go on for 30 freaking years
anything short of that George is them
playing they're playing patty cake
they're playing cleanup and there's not
going to be any way to get out of this
thing their marriage isn't going to
survive it their finances sure aren't
going to survive it um they are broke
broke broke broke broke broke Scary
broke for their age yeah that's step one
if if and when you get to that point
where You' had that conversation to come
to Jesus meeting and it goes well then
we can start attacking the debt and pay
down this 130,000 with a six figure
salary you should be able to do that in
two to three years if you're not doing
anything else oh there's no sixf
figureure salary anymore um he got
bought out and then he blew it so now
she works full-time and he does contract
contract work contract works over now
he's gonna work three jobs that's right
he's gonna work three jobs
we need to get back to a sixf figure
salary if we're going to have any hope
of cleaning this up and retiring one day
because he also depleted the retirement
account right down to almost nothing so
you're going to have to rebuild that and
uh so retirement is it's not even in
your vocabulary for the next decade you
guys are going to be working working
working and I hope one day you get the
mortgage paid off and you can retire and
this marriage can be saved but it starts
with those hard conversations yeah and
this might be a situation where you got
to sell your house and you got to
downsize and you got to go to an
apartment uh um that's of much less Val
I mean it costs a lot less money to run
and on a monthly basis because y'all are
y'all are't a mess y'all are't a mess um
I would reach out to one of our Ramy
Financial coaches and talk through the
particulars here Jackie but this is a
scary scary mess and here's the deal um
George you and I talk about this
privately you can when you're facing a
scary mess you can say that is really
scary and do what you've done for this
person Jackie done for 30 years and just
look the other way or you you can stare
a scary mess in the face and turn all
the lights on and say we're going after
it we're going to figure this thing out
right get the gloves on we're going to
work yeah oh that sucks this that makes
this makes my stomach sink yep don't let
that be you guys address the stuff never
brush her under the rug to avoid
conflict that never works out if you are
married to someone and they say don't
worry I'll just take care of it do not
accept that and if you're a person of
integrity and I'll go this far if you're
a quote unquote I'm the head of the
household I'm the man around here and
you're so much of a coward that you
won't sit down with your wife and say
this is how our money works this is
where we put our bills this is a and you
don't bring somebody in on it shame on
you this is both of you doing this
together enough is enough is enough man
create your free every dollar budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life